خلفت الفيضانات المدمرة التي
اجتاحت ليبيا الأسبوع الماضي أكثر
من 11 ألف قتيل في مدينة
درنة، وذلك وفقًا لتقرير للأمم المتحدة
يقول أيضًا إن أكثر من 40 ألف شخص
نزحوا عبر
شمال شرق البلاد، والآن يتوقع المسؤولون أن هذه
الأرقام من المرجح أن تكون  مع استمرار
فرق الطوارئ في البحث عن المفقودين، تم
حتى الآن انتشال عشرات الجثث
من البحر على طول
ساحل دينا، وتم تحميل العديد منها على شاحنات ونقلها
إلى
مثواها الأخير، وفي بعض الحالات،
ورد أن الجثث دُفنت في مقابر جماعية.
لكن وكالات الإغاثة تعمل أيضًا
على محاولة توفير مراسم دفن كريمة. وتقوم
دول مثل المملكة العربية السعودية وتركيا
بإرسال دعم إضافي بما في ذلك
الإمدادات الطبية والغذاء وموظفي الطوارئ
للمساعدة في الإغاثة في حالات الكوارث.